feeling safe is still a novelty for
reason and
and freedom
big difference yeah this is the high low
dianov's first walk outside hospital
since his release from Russian captivity
a Ukrainian Marine this was him just
five months ago defending the azov
Styles still works in Mario poll before
the city finally fell and this is how he
looked last week after four months in
Russian detention his broken arm healed
in a semi-circle his body emaciated the
deterioration shocking
the series
[Music]
the Hilo was among 215 Ukrainian
prisoners taken in May after weeks Under
Siege in mariopol recently released in a
high profile exchange with Russia he's
the first to speak publicly following
their captivity and this is his first
interview
distribution
[Music]
were you ever worried you wouldn't
survive
yeah this is the moment Mahalo was
reunited with his family
such relief but so frail
after Russian troops captured him and
the azov style fighters in mariopol they
were taken to olinifica prison in
russian-controlled Donetsk
a place he refers to as a concentration
camp he was packed into a block with 800
others
the prison was bombed in July killing
more than 50 people an attack Mahalo
narrowly escaped instead he'd been
enduring a reckless operation on his arm
at a different location carried out with
a pair of pliers and no anesthesia
than this the moment he was released
absolutely
um
he was blindfolded with tape and forced
to travel like that for a day and a half
before he realized he was back in
Ukraine
he now needs to gain 20 kilos before
corrective surgery on his arm but he
says thousands more ukrainians the still
living these Horrors in the prison he
feels lucky to have survived
Sally Lockwood Sky News Kiev